earlier this year the makers of barbie
came out this is
this is real they came out with an
eleanor roosevelt
barbie doll yes yes
finally answering the demand of young
girls yes
no this was the best i get yes
apparently this was to celebrate women's
history month
and um i wasn't sure if barbie and
eleanor roosevelt
would be a natural fit i i i
it just when you first hear it you don't
think oh yeah right
you wonder but then i saw this
commercial
for the barbie eleanor roosevelt
and it changed my mind introducing
eleanor roosevelt barbie
one of the most awesome women of the
20th century
she wants to play just like you let's do
a baking show on youtube
no let's do a show about fashion why
don't we host a weekly radio show to
lift the spirits of poverty-stricken
americans who are suffering during the
great depression
bring her on all of your adventures
we're getting surfing at malibu beach
want to come illinois sure i'd love to
the retaining walls along the malibu
coastline were built by the works
projects administration
a new deal program i promoted that gave
the americans work and dignity
we i love surfing these waves are more
fun than the waves of fascism that were
sweeping across europe when i was alive
i vigorously opposed the appeasement of
hitler that joe kennedy advised
when my husband franklin made him
ambassador of great britain
for me going to war was a tragic but
necessary sacrifice
eleanor roosevelt barbie film footage
from world war
ii newsreel sold separately